bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti vi sono
video sono fatti sono felicissima ogni
volta che parto questo gioco perché è la
vita
molto semplicemente se un su turbo
dismount il caso non si fosse capito ma
si fosse capito è un gioco che permette
di fare degli incidenti carini con la
faccia di pietro quindi mettete mi piace
dato che si sono mappe nuove tanto io
non ci sono le mappe che non ho visto
[Musica]
non ci credo ha infatti mi sembrava
tutto troppo tranquillo bene dicevo ci
sono le mappe che non ho visto il suo
gioco tipo questa non l'avevo mai
giocata fatto poi fare il giro di tutta
la mappa e allora vai dentro eletto
dentro che c'è la neve lento lento c'è
un motivo se non mi hanno dato la
patente ma non so se questo non sono
sicuro alla prima col triciclo che mi
sembra ecco esatto cambia la posizione
perfetto cosi non dovresti avere
problemi con come stai pedalando
esattamente stemmi sia facile e sta roba
raga la vedo malissimo però saranno bene
è perfetto forse è meglio che non parli
occhio che c'è ancora
celani pupazzi neve perfetto records
devo trovare il modo migliore per girare
senza che mischianti perché si possono
cambiare i percorsi che uno può fare
quando si butta in mezzo alla pista
se riuscissi a non cadere sarebbe meglio
provare
ok all'inter e stavolta forse posso
riuscirci
la cosa che devi fare è cercare di
seguire l'andamento della pista però non
andare addosso alle macchine almeno il
triciclo intatto almeno quello
pietro no pietro non è il triciclo se
avevi che prova senza pietro va
benissimo era era lui il problema ha
capito senza pietre fattibilissima sta
roba è lui che ha un peso specifico
sbagliato guardano le quanto triste eder
bravo pietro let's go niente c'è una
macchina c'è una e tu quella de vivre
dopo quella precisa però fino a prova
contraria sono ancora col triciclo
in teoria non dovrei neanche essere
morto doveva farlo con una macchina con
decente tipo anzi anzi anzi se
permettete eccolo lì miley cyrus è let's
go
ci mancava solo questo governo arrivi ci
arrivi ci arrivi c a d occhio che butti
giù va bene tutto bene niente eh vabbè
allora guarda a sta tornando qua puoi
non passarmi di soap poi poi rallentare
no era era la mia macchina ci tengo a
precisarlo
dove ragazzi rechi cambiare mappa se il
possibile perché non mi sembra proprio
il massimo per the city raikes che ha
molte bella musica visto gioco no no no
non andare con lei ormai loro
schiacciato però in teoria sta roba
dovrebbe volare non andare sulle rotelle
sono non è proprio la navicella mia mi
ha staccato un alla polizia perché cos'è
ma volano sede scemi
perché mi seguiva la polizia con il loro
problema no non andare non andare non
c'è il muro grazie a dio mi sembra
veramente comodo bene
vabbè allora fermi nudi se c'è la
polizia deve assolutamente mettere il
carrello se permettete ai frate mai
frate non si sa con quale motore esiste
spingendo ma vai male
occhio che mi sa che fortunatamente
c'era l'albero però c'era anche questa
macchina purtroppo ma cosa contro di me
la polizia non ho capito ford crichi
cosa stava non l'ho mai provata ragazzi
a un trenino va bene provaci
con quale fisica per la vive della
polizia non mi ha ancora visto l'hiv
aids io ci sono riuscito a passare con
trenini in mezzo al traffico
occhio come [ __ ] la pula lesson
number one di avercela fatta in teoria
mi fosse investito da solo con il
carrello
però posso andare con la macchina la
polizia politica perfetto vai guido
guido io
ecco forse è meglio evitare che guidi la
prossima volta non riescono mai a
colpirmi sti qua se vado piano forse è
più regolabile speriamo di riuscire
almeno a fare la salita occhio occhio
occhio degli impediti non riescono a
prendermi ma come di agire agire agire
ruota destra a destra e destra ma come
ho fatto a scacciarla auto non mi sono
scontrato contro niente porca vacca sto
prendendo gusto
va bene sono bravo a guidare non avrei
mai detto non vedo se passano macchina
in mezzo mi fido del fatto che non
passeranno
mi fido male salve mi hanno preso
finalmente ma non mi potete fermare non
potete nulla contro di me stavo
scherzando per ho vinto io mi sa è
cambiato la mappa che dite colpisci la
pala eolica ha già questo era veramente
la data croce parte che puoi mettere le
rampe quindi va beh probabilmente questo
con la macchina non questa della polizia
ma quella velocissima la formula 1
eccola in teoria questa combo dovrebbe
funzionare da dio in teoria vai
dove di là di lazio va beh apprezzo il
tentativo forse prendiamo una rampa più
piccola che dite non so se basta è però
ci proviamo
vai
mi sa che è bastardo cosa vedo normale
normale per niente capolavori voluto
vedere il replay che scemo riproviamoci
non ce la farò mai beccare full speed di
nuovo
ma come e vabbè cose accadono se finisco
pure sulle bombe ciao ma che peccato
la mia macchina non ho neanche idea di
dove sia finita ma il replay me lo
guardo volentieri
ecco la cosa più bella visto gioco
l'apoteosi della bellezza sono i replay
vedere o mio dio come che miraggio avuto
scusami ma che ha preso la botta
fortissimo non qua dopo
minchia che schiaffo bellissimo la
macchina andata ad avere va bene per ora
la mia mappa preferita sono autorizzato
a dirlo questo prova con la moto che
dite magari non così ecco esatto così
vai vai vai vai led dovere veramente non
ho beccato le fa eco adesso tutto chiaro
prima mi ero fatto un danno cioè che non
riuscirò mai deviare quel record trochei
prova ad andare un pelo più piano quello
delle scope care le palle all'inizio
pampa con è l'aver perfetto ora quanto
fatto prima i danni ci è impossibile non
lo guarderò mai
la testa dove era finita è finita la
testa malissimo
what the fuck ultimo tentativo raga con
la moto almeno perché questa parte
veramente divertente se permettete la
faccio un paio di volte a posto col
pullman
va bene questo mi se questo sono curioso
di capire anche solo se arrivo alle pale
sono messi
sono fiducioso ecco parliamo ad avere
meno fiducia sarà jamboree
ma che bella dimmi che ti puoi mettere
sulla cosa di sopra sulla tavola da surf
ti prego è infatti ma è bellissima e
geniale ovvero vado che brutta roba era
bellissima è rimasta nella posizione
tratto da surf e continua a stare una
posizione da surf ok posso metterlo più
storto però ecco così così mi sembra
carina penso che faccia male se lo
prende in pieno nei gioielli mi
sorprendono sa questo livello per ora il
più bello in assoluto para mi dispiace
cambiarlo però select level è stato
veramente illuminante come livello
voglio vedere se riesco a fare un l'ex
keep going ha già questo dovevi scendere
al macello può vedere se devi arrivare
alla però era veramente difficile
infatti non ci sono mai riuscito tutto a
posto
cambiamo perché non penso di poter fare
meglio di così bigg è compo
questo è quello col punteggio me lo
ricordo che partenza è ma manco ma manco
sei arrivato complimenti ma è un pelo
più lento che dice ok ma neanche anche
forse sì ok più lento ci arriva dalla
kia posizione che male non la rete se
siete donne forse l'avete sentito di
meno i maschi l'hanno sentito ve lo
giuro che male l anche va bene di sicuro
e pietro abituato a questi tre ti dico
va bene
proviamoci bravo vai dritto dritto
dritto dritto no sono entrato dentro va
bene ma trovo fatto prima 80 adesso
credo sia record speriamo con la
macchina più veloce il problema è che
questa la devo prendere lenta perché va
giù subito se vado veloce faccio un
salto ancora prima tipo 2
e invece no
e invece no tensione simola martin
garics 130 ho fatto 130 di punteggio tra
120 e 140 anzi non se contiamo dove è
caduto lui ho fatto anche 150 150 è
record per la tele squadra po più lento
e forse faccio di più
no 110 120 perfetto record era quello di
prima dovrei trovare una macchina un po
piccola ma che vada tipo questa mi sa di
no
ok però andare più veloce di così buono
buono 140 lo sa forgia orca vacca sempre
130 art ingari la moto così
buono buono buono mi chiamò a volo 160
150 160 record ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come si dice vicino quando mi
piace anche ai soci come iscrizione sono
stato questi iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]